I'm a biological oceanographer I have
the absolute privilege of studying
microbial lives in the Pacific Ocean so
we'll talk about microbes in a minute
but I first want to give you a sense of
place a sense of scale the Pacific Ocean
is our largest deepest ocean basin
covers 60 million square miles if you
took all the continents and you put them
together in a little Pangaea 2.0 they'd
fit snug inside the Pacific right with
room to spare
it's a massive ecosystem from the Blues
of the open ocean to the green of the
continental margins in this place I get
to study the base of the food web
plankton
now in my research and and really in the
field of microbial oceanography as a
whole there's a theme that has emerged
and that theme is change these microbial
ecosystems are changing in real and
measurable ways and it is not that hard
to see it oceans cover 70% of our planet
so ocean change is planetary change and
it all starts with microbes now I have
two vignettes to share with you and
these are meant to be love stories to
microbes but I'll be honest that there's
an aspect of it that's just a total
bummer and beware focus on the love all
right that's where I'm coming from so
the first thing to know is that the
forests of the sea are microbial and
what I mean by that is that by and large
plants in the open ocean are microscopic
and they are much more abundant than we
realize
so I'm going to show you some mug shots
of these organisms that I've collected
over the years these are the lowest
rungs of the ocean food web these are
tiny plants and animals they come in a
variety of shapes and sizes and colors
and metabolisms there are hundreds of
thousands and a sea
milliliter of seawater you are
definitely swimming with them when
you're in the ocean they produce oxygen
they consume co2 and they form the base
of the food web on which every other
form of ocean life is reliant now I've
spent about 500 days of my scientific
life at sea and a lot more in front of a
computer in the lab so I feel compelled
to tell you some of their stories let's
start in the Pacific Northwest
this place is Green is beautiful these
are blooms of phytoplankton that you can
see from space along the west coast the
United States
it's an incredibly productive easy
ecosystem this is where you go to salmon
fish halibut fish whale watch it's a
beautiful part of our country and here
for ten years
among other things I studied the
uplifting topic of harmful algal blooms
great these are blooms of toxin
producing phytoplankton that can
contaminate food webs and accumulate in
shellfish and fish that are harvested
for human consumption we were trying to
understand why they bloom where they
bloom when they bloom so we could manage
these harvests and protect human health
now the problem is the oceans a moving
target and much like some people in our
lives
toxicity varies among the plankton all
right so to get around these challenges
we combine satellite remote sensing with
drones and gliders regular sampling of
the surf zone and a lot of time at sea
in small boats off the Oregon coast and
I don't know if many of you have had the
opportunity to do that but it is not
easy here's some for students all right
I've hidden their faces to predict their
identities it's a challenging place so
this is hard-won data I'm about to talk
about okay so by combining all of our
data with our collaborators we had 20
year time series of toxins and
phytoplankton cell counts and that
allowed us
understand the patterns of these blooms
and to build models to predict them and
what we found was that the risk of
harmful algal blooms was tightly linked
to aspects of climate and I say climate
I don't mean weather day-to-day I mean
long-term changes these oscillations
that you may have heard of the Pacific
decadal oscillation El Nino they usually
bring warm dry winters to this region
but they also reduced the strength of
the California Current which runs from
the north to the south along the Pacific
Northwest and they warm the coastal
ocean these are the reds you're seeing
in this plot warm anomalies strong
positive indices of the PDO and when we
have these changes in circulation and
changes in temperature the risk of
harmful algal blooms is increased but
also salmon recruitment has decreased
and we see intrusions of invasive
species like green crab all right so
these are ecological and economic
impacts of climate now if our models are
right the frequency and severity of
these events are only going to get worse
right along with these warm anomalies
and to illustrate that 2014 was probably
one of the worst harmful algal blooms in
Oregon history it was also the hottest
year in the modern climate record at
that time that is until 2015 2016 2017
in fact the five hottest years in the
modern climate record have been the last
five that bodes really well for harmful
algal blooms and poorly for ecosystem
health now you may not care about
shellfish but these changes impact
economically important fisheries like
crab and salmon and they can impact the
health of marine mammals like whales
right and that that might matter a
little bit more that might resonate so
there's your doomsday tail for the
margins of the Pacific actually these
are these are really resilient
ecosystems they can absolutely bounce
back if we give them a chance
the point is not to
nor the changes that we're seeing which
brings me to my second vignette I have
since moved to the most remote island
chain on our planet the Hawaiian Islands
where I'm the new lead of a program
called the Hawaiian ocean time series
and this is a program that for 31 years
has made this monthly pilgrimage to a
spot called station Aloha it's in the
middle of the Pacific Ocean in the
center of this vast swirling system of
currents that we call the North Pacific
subtropical gyre it's our largest soak
ocean ecosystem it's four times the size
of the Amazon rainforest is warm and a
good way is blue water it's absolutely a
type of place you want to dive in and
swim you cannot do that off of research
boats because you know sharks google it
this is a beautiful place and here since
October of 1988 generations of
researchers have made these monthly
pilgrimages we study the biology the
chemistry the physics of the open ocean
we've measured the temperature from the
surface to the sea floor we've tracked
the currents trace the waves we have
people have discovered new organisms
here people created vast genomic
libraries that have revolutionized what
we think about the diversity of marine
microorganisms it's not just a place of
discovery but the important part about
time series are they provide us a sense
of history a sense of context and in 30
years of data it's allowed us to
separate the seasonal change and see the
emergence of humanity's fingerprints on
the natural world there's another iconic
time series in Hawaii and that is the
Keeling curve I hope you have all seen
this this time series has documented the
rapid increase in carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere it's not just the number it's
the rate of increase the rate of carbon
dioxide increase in our atmosphere is
unprecedented for our planet and that
has consequences for our oceans
in fact oceans absorb about 90% of the
heat that's generated by greenhouse gas
emissions and about 40% of the carbon
dioxide
and we have been able to measure that at
station Aloha each one of these dots is
a cruise it represents people's lives
over 30 years trying to make these
measurements and it took 30 years to be
able to see this co2 rises in that
Monsieur co2 rises in the ocean that's
the red line a consequence that of that
is a fundamental change in the chemistry
of seawater a decline in pH pH is on a
log scale here's your blue line so we've
seen a 30% decline in pH and the surface
ocean in this time series now that has
impacts for organisms that need to feed
build shells that changes growth rates
metabolic interactions and it doesn't
just impact plankton and impacts
ecosystems as large as coral reefs now
one of the things we've been able to
show in this time series is this is just
skimming the surface increases in co2
and a decline in pH are measured over
the top 500 meters of the water column I
really find that to be profound this is
genuinely one of the most remote places
on our planet and we've impacted the top
500 meters of the water column now these
two things harmful algal blooms ocean
acidification that's not all of course
you've heard of the rest sea level rise
beautification melting of the polar ice
caps expansion of oxygen minimum zone
solution loss of biodiversity
overfishing it's hard for me to get a
grad student you can see this pitch is a
difficult one right again I think these
systems these microbial ecosystems are
immensely resilient we just cannot go
too far down this path I personally
believe that sustained observation of
our oceans and our planet is the moral
imperative for our generation of
scientists we are bearing witness to the
changes that are being inflicted upon
our natural communities and by doing so
it provides us the opportunity to adapt
and enact global change if we're willing
so the solutions to these problems are
multi-tiered involves a portfolio
solutions local change but all the way
up to voting for people who will protect
our environment on the global scale
[Applause]
let's bring it back to the love microbes
matter these organisms are small
abundant ancient and they are critical
sustaining our population and our planet
yet we are on track to double our carbon
dioxide emissions in the next 50 years
so the analogy that I use for that is
like we are we're eating like we're
still in our 20s
assuming it'll be no consequences but
I'm a woman in her 40s I know there are
consequences for my fuel consumption
right these oceans are very much alive
these ecosystems have not collapsed but
well except for the Arctic we could talk
about that but these sustained
observations that I've shared with you
today the work of generations of
scientists are pointing us to take
better care of our oceans and to nurture
the microbes that sustain us and on that
note I want to end with a quote from one
of my heroes Jane Lubchenco and this
slide is appropriate
Jane has said that the oceans are not
too big to fail nor are they too big to
fix but the oceans are too big to ignore
thank you
[Applause]